[Music]
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing about you oh wow um that's a very
interesting question because you never
think about that and I was always raised
to be humble I think the most beautiful
thing about me is my empathy my ability
to connect with other people you know an
inner beauty not necessarily an outer
that I have another half what do you
mean by that my beautiful wonderful wife
can my wife count if she's done the
thing did she but I'm open to new ideas
and that I love people for who they are
and I love them to be different I guess
that's what I love about people same as
I love about me I feel like I always
have a smile on my face so I feel like
that just like radiates to other people
and
I don't know it's hard not to smile back
on a smile
I just turned 70 and I think I'm
beautiful and it makes me feel happy
that at least I'm lost 70 another thing
is I have a giving nature
my eyes probably my eyes my intelligence
my love for nature my spirit virtue
probably my kindness my children my
heart my heart it has to be my heart yes
hopefully my heart
do you want to take turns saying
something beautiful about the other
person
bread I love your feet I think
everything
probably my beard probably my beard yeah
I like dogs
that's probably this hair and I like the
curls hey yeah it's been a lot of time
on those my color like my smile and my
smiley probably the fact that I look
Asian but I'm not a lot of people think
that I'm a using bum full Mexican oh
really and I think that's pretty pretty
unique I would say sense of humor to be
honest because I think more people need
to smile especially at a time like what
we're in now people kind of go away from
that and I think even a little bit helps
that would have to be my sole full-on
the deeper waters are the most beautiful
ones well physically I really like my
hair and like unfortunately wife I like
that I'm very determined like if I see a
goal I'm gonna get it and something I
really like about me what's your biggest
glory to graduate med school my desire
to transform
to change as I evolve and see what
things I'd like to change about myself
and reach for that what's the biggest
change you've made recently
I'm currently just traveling full-time
and I have been for the last six months
that's been a huge change because I'm
not living anywhere I study working
anywhere I study my life is just all
about change and new experiences right
now I think that like I'm generally like
a positive person and like I like to see
like the good in people and like not you
know even if someone does something like
rude or kind of like me and I like to
think like well maybe there's like a
reason behind it so I'd like to think
that maybe I could say my conscious my
conscious is one of most beautiful
things about me I have a really big
conscious and sometimes it's kind of
that's a bad thing because I'm so good
but I don't know I have that inner good
in me I do a good deed each day even if
it's like a little thing like even if
it's doing this today check good deed
done because you know people like to
take advantage of the good things in
life meaning people as well so there's
been a couple of times so I'm just like
I know what you're about to do but my
consciousness there it goes again
and I'll be like I'll let you slide
today but tomorrow it's gonna be a
different day
not like my personality but always
trying to like make people happy and see
their own beauty so I don't really see
that as like a physical feature but
something I could do to help
guys my name is Raya and I'm the owner
of this channel I'm also the person
behind the camera and I thought I'd take
a minute to thank all the subscribers I
gained so far and maybe ask the new
viewers to the subscribe button if you
liked this episode or if you're a fan of
my channel in general I mean a lot thank
you